these haitians say their homes are no
longer a safe place in the midst of gang
wars they've sought shelter at an empty
school
sixteen-year-old michele zhong was at
home one saturday when he was hit by a
stray bullet
there was no school that day we stayed
at home and there was a lot of shooting
many people were killed many people were
shot and some didn't have a chance to
save themselves the situation is really
bad
hundreds of people are sleeping in
classrooms
some on shared mattresses others on the
cold floor
many children came here without their
parents
one community leader says they wore
their school uniforms so gangsters would
think they were going to class
[Music]
the children said that the situation had
worsened on saturday 16th of july that
they couldn't find water to drink that
they couldn't find food that they wanted
to go out so on sunday we went to take
them out
others are still trapped in the city's
poorest neighborhood caught up in a turf
war
un agencies say they can do nothing it's
too dangerous those who did manage to
escape are scarred by what they
experienced
i found the bullet next to my head i was
sleeping and i heard the bullet i had a
child with me and i told him to get
under the bed
violent crime has increased since the
assassination of president jovel moyes
last year
the political instability has emboldened
gangs
haiti's government has been unable to
end the bloodshed
forcing children like these to do what
they can to save themselves
he and bruce al jazeera